a video yes I've never seen two whole
goats in a biryani before
first I'm tenderizing them with vinegar
then they'll be stuffed with chickens
quails and eggs and served on a bed of
fragrance okay okay okay now we're
coating the goats in ginger and chili
you just five five I just like that
empty ours makes it clear that great
indian cookery is instinctive there's no
recipe as such
whenever the new student comes and you
try to learn so you should respect the
the teacher you know I definitely
respect the teacher trust men it looks
like a guy I don't want to fall out with
okay in terms of technique this dish is
as complex as anything in Michelin star
cookery I'm now marinating the chicken
and the quails in the chili ginger
garlic and yogurt mix what is a basic
take away in Britain is a finely tuned
feasting dish in India back in the UK
every carry house 99% of them used the
same base for the source here it's
completely different individual curry
individual source
there's no same base as all becoming so
much clearer
no I think it's perfectly okay what's
the largest wedding your father's ever
cooked for me :
building some day come to come watch our
pajamas are a cake laugh at me he sings
almost fifty thousand to one lakh people
I've done fifty thousand oh my god Oh
Sammy Anna really keen people from all
over the world from President to and
minister to always cater to everyone
MGRS
has got a bigger head than me I looked
up the chance to work for him yeah when
he was a Rottweiler then I'm the age of
35 yeah
look at the hands I like shovels look oh
my god amazing amazing amazing amazing
for as strong as an ox
this father was always 135 years old his
father 135 years oh Jesus seriously I
have seen him in my childhood your
father was a being 35 years Brandon we
put too much Oprah on the fire the one
thing in G ours isn't bullshitting about
is the food
the hard pulled eggs are coated in
saffron egg inside the quail I haven't
had a masterclass like this since my
commie chef days in Paris that way
the eggs go inside the quail the quail
inside the chicken
and finally we stuff it all in the goat
it's almost like sort of rewinding
giving birth now you're putting it back
in once it's been born we're gonna
stitch it well it was a dish that was
put together for bite Alicia your shot
though laughs right this this dish was
made for only for a king but don't light
it on just make him stand or stand up
this show Pizza supermarket curry ready
meal